When you get a Lego set from the store,
the pieces inside are in
sealed little bags.
Larger sets like this one
have multiple sealed bags.
All of the pieces in one bag create just
a portion, or component, of the model.
After building each of the components,
you can combine them together
to form the completed model.
An Angular module is just
like this cardboard box.
It's a container that houses all of
the different components of an angular
application.
If the box is like a module,
then this bag might be a controller, and
this little bag could be the router or
a service.
Applications aren't limited
to just one module.
When an application becomes
more complex, it's a good idea
to break out the different features
of the application into modules.
This keeps your app more organized,
manageable and easier to test.
When we used a Yoman to generate our
app, we gave it the name udaciMeals.
This became the default module for
the app.
The generator creates
the apps model inside appJs.
The module is created by
calling Angular.module,
passing it the name of the module, which
can be anything but automatically uses
the name provided on the terminal, and
passing it in a ray of dependencies.
Remember that Angular applications
can have more than one module.
If this app depended on other modules,
then those modules are required for
this app to function.
Those modules names
would be listed here.
So, this tells the angular to
create the udaciMealsApp module and
that it depends on dep1 and dep2.
This tells Angular to create
the udaciMeals app module,
and that it doesn't depend
on any other modules.
So this creates the module.
To get the module,
we would write angular.module, and
give it the name of
the module we want to get.
These two forms are very similar,
but do totally different things.
If you're creating a module,
make sure you pass an array
as the second argument,
even if the module does not depend on
anything, it needs to have that array.
Also make sure that you create your
module before you try getting it, or
Angular will complain.